I was swinging in a hammock I'm drinking
a good time I'm at good times one you're
gonna crash so hard I filled with the
boys today we're having three cocktails
at three different places at three
drastically different price point andrew
is gonna be the one bringing me along
because I honestly don't know much
anything about alcohol I am by no means
an expert but I know what I like and
we're gonna find out what you like we're
going to a little place called good
times at Davey Wayne's they serve an
old-fashioned that is fashioned in a new
kind of way you'll see you'll see just
just wait till we're there we haven't
even had a drink yet and you just don't
copy all over my car look you're just
gonna have to let that dry out my name
is Mark DOS this is good times at Davey
Wayne's a 70s bar owned by Houston
hospitality Davey Wayne is their father
and so it has a lot of heart a lot of
history for them we put a old fashioned
on tap because that was his favorite
drink happy old-fashioned is six dollars
that goes Monday through Friday from 5
o'clock when we open till 8 o'clock what
goes into an old-fashioned it's actually
the original cocktail cocktail doesn't
mean everything under the Sun it
originally means spirit water sugar and
bitters four hours is old Overholt rye
whiskey sugar and bitters we take the
measurements that we know work for the
old fashioned batch them together at our
dilution already nitrogen is what pushes
the old fashioned through so nitrogen
compared to co2 creates this creaminess
almost that you wouldn't get from a
normal fashion put ourselves a orange
peel in a lemon peel when we peel and
Express over the cocktail it's gonna lay
a fine layer of citrus oil so when you
go up and you take a sip you're smelling
all these citrus these bright notes it's
a really great balance together
really enhances the whiskey boys night
out two peas in a pod
my ideal Friday night hang out with my
boys sup Adam - good times
[Music]
here's my favorite part of this drink
right here it's that initial hit up
sweet that you get from the smell hmm
old-fashioned sounds like something that
isn't gonna taste good but this is
actually quite delicious
you got that really delightful cherry
that I'm excited to get to at the bottom
it's both very easy to drink and it's
cheap those are two ideal ingredients -
boys night out with Adam and receivin
tart mode Oh God we're in the middle of
Hollywood but suddenly we're kind of
transported to a backyard barbecue it
really feels like a home you got couches
you got cool paintings this movie line
what's it winter here should we play
never have I ever
yeah never ever been arrested I've never
been arrested never have I ever dyed my
hair
that's cheating never have I ever been a
loser still got all three guys drinking
there I got a drink there all right Adam
get in here big boy
the drinks are really coming in right
now into my blood system I was satisfied
I paid six dollars for a polity drink
and even better you don't have to wait
around for someone to meticulously make
it you just grab it and go yes nobody
knows exactly where the word cocktail
comes from but cocktail used to refer to
when horses would flap their tails up
like a rooster huh well that's not
helpful all right next place you are
going to be blown away is it extravagant
it's a little bit extravagant in a
fantasy sort of way yes
[Music]
my name is Matt Messina my bartender
here at Pacific seeds I'm Andru Myron
and I'm the proprietor here and we're on
the fourth floor third floor fourth
fourth floor we're on the fourth floor
of Clifton's when I first came in I was
trying to find the Pacific Seas I ran to
a mirror and I said sorry to myself cuz
I thought I'd ran into myself you come
through the doors we're not gonna tell
you where to go you're gonna go find it
yourself
it's all about exploration so the idea
is you get lost it's like a cooler
version of Ikea
I'm with much better drinks today were
gonna be drinking a scorpion bowl this
dates back to the 1930s actually was
originated in Honolulu in that we have
lime juice or shot orange juice and then
fill your scorpion bowl with ice then
add your liquors white rum which we use
in El Dorado three use cognac which is
Hennessy for us and then we also use gin
which is aviation pour that over the
fresh ice add your garnishes use lemon
extract instead of 151 it's a lot less
dangerous then you light that on fire
and then you can use whatever you want
to kind of spark it we use cinnamon and
it gives it a nice like little volcanic
eruption ready same time sure
make-a-wish safety first kids all right
straw Cheers crossing straws about the
drinking from the same drink guys
[Music]
whoo-hoo I bet you like that yeah this
is party time it is really like
Tropicana fruit punch I could down
probably one of these by myself if I'm
not careful yeah you can really sit and
savor this it sits in the center of the
table and everybody just takes a turn
from the watering hole the perfect
friendship drink sure is are you sick
and I have a cold but it's a scorpion
bowl so my cold is the least you got to
worry about I don't love bars but this
is a very fun bar there's stuff
everywhere and according to the guy it's
all authentic that's really cool
it's like Disneyland for adults am i
escaping or am I really
entering entering who I really am I
don't know what time it is it doesn't
matter what time it is
I don't exist in this bar as you know me
I'm a cartographer making maps of places
that you've never even imagined yeah
yeah totally what is the purpose of
being here I'm black we've shared like
one doughnut how do I say this
you know when people drink too much and
they get close to you and they just like
read on you it's called dragon breath
your straws for a reason you animal I
love this bowl Adam
you want in
[Music]
all right so it's dark in here but we
threw up my phone it's brand new okay
that's all you to tape it yeah look at
that I'm ready for a shaken not stirred
cocktail this the cocktail that are
online oh it is currently in this a
tissue box wedged between the headrest
in the ceiling or the FAQ see am I good
let's just make that was one it was a
good bag yeah one a good bag here's your
cocktail bag British soldiers in India a
long time ago had to take tonic water
because the quinine in it did some stuff
in their body preventing malaria it
tasted gross so they added gin to it and
that's where you get your gin and tonic
from wow I like that you know things
should have a purpose
take for example uh you what's your
purpose it's gonna say fashion so we're
on our way to the last location the last
cocktail tonight guys it's been an
amazing boys night out it can't and here
see now you're getting it so the last
place we're going to tonight is a bit
fancier tell me the name part of the
experience is not knowing the name it's
driving me crazy
[Music]
welcome to 10-pound my name is Kash
black and this is the official outpost
in the Cowan Scotch whisky and today I'm
going to serve you the Highland Park 30
penicillin we just rewind a little bit
you said your name is cash black that is
right
Warner raised in Las Vegas Nevada what a
name okay I'm myself but not much of a
drinker what makes this particular
alcohols so special any alcohol aged
over about 18 years is you know it's
phenomenal in the sense that it actually
survived there's a lot what they call
the devil's cut which actually
evaporates and the best thing about
Highland Park 30 is one of my favorites
because it's really smooth and gentle
and it's going to show you all those key
flavors that are normally associated
with the Scotch but you're gonna have
none of the hang time mm-hmm yeah are we
doing a bad thing by having this Scotch
as a penicillin you know I tell people
every time they ask me if you can have
it the way you like it especially for a
person who's never had Scotch before
it's usually a cocktail that I give them
to be like this is the bridge to
actually enjoying scotch first you're
going to have a half ounce of honey then
also you have a little bit of lemon
juice the idea of that is to give it a
little bit of a bump to bring out that
citrus in that orange then also you have
ginger juice which is actually going to
pair with that Pete and actually
counteract it a little bit finally
that's when we add the Highland Park 30
shake it put it over our 10-pound ice
fear which has our logo etched with a
laser on the inside of the ball and it's
dyin eyes water which means it's going
to take on the chemical properties of
whichever spirits you put it with I
usually do just a little lemon zest over
the top of it that's all you need fellas
these glasses are six hundred and fifty
dollars a piece ooh
so please Cheers gingerly all right it's
good for me and now I am so happy that
somebody has arraigned in your chair
same for me also this is a pleasant
surprise what we have here is curry
masala spiced pecans a 26 month age
gotta cheese and applewood smoked bacon
fresh out of the oven this is
complimentary and is actually designed
to bring out a different note within
your scotch
so try meet you individually and enjoy
your little owls on the glass they
actually make four in a very nice grip
so you ready to I just try to act like
we're in a nice place gentle tears
don't even touch okay touch right Harry
jinx
yeah it just like fizzles and it's like
this bang in your mouth and it's awesome
I think it's really interesting that you
take a sip of this drink and it's bright
and pretty at first and then you get
this wash of kind of smoke and darkness
happening shadow of the Scotch kind of
just cast over you're like huh what that
is truly what the show is - by the way
we got the bright beautiful colors here
and then the spooky shadow with its
cloud over the show Adams the $650
crystal glass that it's too precious -
precious for this world
I won't try the bacon yeah uh yes
suddenly that shadow is not so spooky
haha this bacon is a rainbow it's a
beacon of light let's cover the cheese
sure looks like a little nugget of gold
it's all about the preachings baby
that is really really different who
would have known that when you eat
different foods things taste different
in your mouth you've made so much growth
on this show right you don't people talk
about alcohol they talk about like the
notes and the complexity and like the
different flavors and and you're just
like what I'm actually experiencing that
here you know
boys night over
do you like the apples yeah ten pound
yeah Wow ten pounds of pleasure per
square minute of being there what was
your most worth it winter well let me
let me take you down memory lane good
times at Davey Wayne's I thought when we
left there that was gonna be the
clear-cut winner six bucks for a quality
good tasting cocktail can't beat that
but I can't believe I'm saying this ten
pound is my worth it winner today really
she's I'm shocked
for me drinking is not about getting
drunk I want it to be something that I
can like walk away with a whole new
perspective best buds right best buds
ten pound bar can you even call that a
bar it's more like a secret Scotch Club
kind of wish we had just had the Scotch
straight up but I know that we needed to
get you some juicy cocktail I think my
were that winner overall is Pacific
Caesar Clifton's you're really gonna be
rewarded making the trek all the way to
the Pacific Seas because it is really
special you really do see some you've
never seen before like a boat in the
middle of a bar so we the winner
[Music]
Davey wins he said that he wins he said
a hit house take me home Matt sir buddy
so why do we share should we cut here
leaving out was that the out um no I was
stupid
oh yes